I've heard people say, well,
we only had anal sex. So
delivery time,
I'm done.
Kat Graham and I am a sexual and
spiritual activists and author,
a sex and intimacy guide for couples and
individuals and a meditation teacher.
Uh,
I'm Lance,
I'm a bartender by night and I work
in the entertainment industry by day.
I'm Katie.
I worked in TV and film
up until two years ago.
I've been living there mom
and married life. I'm grace.
I'm 25 years old and I'm a nanny and
the day and then a bartender at night.
I'm Christina,
I'm 34 and I'm an actor and
also a youth leader in ministry.
I'm Brandon. I am 23 years old. I work
in social media. So like in marketing
I have not had
outside nightmare.
Um, that is a true statement. Yes.
And I did clarify like I
have not had sex in general,
so I feel like that went with the prompt.
Cool. Just making sure. Um, you know,
I grew up in the church and so I was
a typical like not going to have sex,
not going to do a B through z.
Um,
I just got out of a two and a half
year relationship coming out of it.
I'm so much more empathetic to how
absolutely tough it is on a day to day.
Yeah.
I,
I did not have sex prior to getting
married almost three years ago.
It made me test.
If this wasn't a serious
relationship going somewhere,
then I could just focus on
kind of my other things.
Okay.
Brandon, I'm curious, um,
the way in which you engaged with your
sexuality and your two and a half year
relationship,
were there things that you could do?
Were there certain things you couldn't
do and is having an orgasm with somebody
considered not being abstinent?
Um, first of all, to act like we didn't
do anything. I'd be lying to you.
I was like,
I'm just purified angel.
Like that there's a white sheet is just
a lie and that's just being up front is
I want to preface with,
is that okay?
I never want to minimize
sin and how I view that.
I never want to run away from that.
Sin is a very heavy thing
and unfortunately for a lot
of things we'd be fighting
and maybe like getting,
doing physical things,
it was easier to either numb
that or to make that fight. Ed,
you know like I'm so mad at you right
now, I don't want to be mad. Boom,
something happens physically.
Right. And then we're like,
I guess we're calling out the
whole orgasms sex thing. Right?
Like that's a thing I still wrestle with.
I don't know.
I don't have a blanket
wide answer for you.
I still danced in the gray area there,
but I know that in my relationship it
was used sometimes it's a beautiful thing
where like it was a natural thing of
love and passion and just being attracted
to each other. But then there
was also times where it wasn't
a lot of things. We can say sex
is like, I've heard people say,
well we only had anal sex so I'm still
a virgin. And to me that's like Whoa,
like regular, like just
regular intercourse, you know,
before I did that. So, but that's me.
Like you're more not a virgin than me.
Yes, I have had sex outside of
marriage in a committed relationship.
Did I want to wait? Absolutely.
The love is a powerful thing.
And when love comes in it
blind a lot and wanted to say,
hey, let's just take this
time and if we're going to
get married, let's just wait.
And we weren't on the same
page when it came to that.
So when that relationship ended,
I made a vow to God and myself to wait.
So I do consider myself a born again
virgin and I'll enjoy sex in marriage like
10 times more than I did outside of it. I
have heard, you know, my whole life, oh,
sex before marriage is a sin.
But then you know,
murdering someone is always a sin.
Right.
But why is sex before marriage after
marriage? It's not a Senate anymore. Yeah,
it's just because you have a piece of
paper saying, Oh, we're married, you know,
now we can have sex.
So I kind of,
I agree with you. We make a big deal
about it being between God and the,
that's the whole reason that
you're abstaining. So why,
why does this,
people are like some kind
of consensus being involved,
like make it valid now they don't bring
validity like it still is between you
and another person in God.
My first time was a positive experience.
My first time was with my
first serious girlfriend, uh,
towards the end of high school.
Disorganized and messy and
um, silly at times. Uh,
but I look back on it really fondly and
we were losing our virginity is together,
which I think was a really
nice thing to share.
I lost my virginity and like one of
my first longterm relationships also,
we were both virgins,
which is good cause like neither of
us know what we were really doing. Um,
so that was, it was awkward,
but it was, it was positive.
I mean I always went into it thinking,
oh,
the first time I have sex it's going
to hurt. It's going to be so bad.
My Heart's going to feel so sad that
I'm, you know, I'm not married and stuff,
but I felt none of that.
I was like, this is great.
Yeah.
My first time was hilarious.
I was almost 28 years old and have
still a virgin on our wedding night.
So the honeymoon it got a lot better.
You know,
argument used so much against abstinence
and celibacy is that how do you know
what you're doing? How do you like,
you're not going to be trained.
I think there's a cool part of learning
that process with each other and
learning that with one person and I think
that's just something that helps you
appreciate it.
Love that person more.
And my first time having sex
was not a negative experience.
It just wasn't necessarily
a positive experience.
I was 14 and I just
decided I had to do it.
I had sex in the back of a hot
rod car with a guy who was,
I think about 18 the way
in which it was positive.
Now when I look back on it is that I
started young and I had a lot of colorful
experiences. Some of them
positive, some of them negative,
but now I'm able to take
all of that experience and
use it to help other people.
Sex,
it can be just physical.
Great.
Okay. Um, I do think it
can just be physical.
I've had sex with people that I've,
I mean,
they were cool,
but like I wasn't interested in
anything else other than sex.
And then that was it. And you know,
they go on and I go on and it was fine.
It's definitely for me personally been
something that has been just physical at
times, um, both in and out
of committed relationships.
I think that's a really
important point to make that,
that sometimes it can
be used as a tool or a,
you know, or as just a, a way to,
to blow off steam after a hard day or
something that just doesn't require a
deeper connection every time.
Um,
reiterate by almost always prefer it
when there is a deeper connection.
It definitely enhances the experience.
Yeah.
Uh,
happen.
So I think that sex can be physical
from someone's own thought process,
but I think you still do, you know,
that there's an emotional side to it.
And so even sometimes I just have friends
that I know, I know that have said,
yeah, this is just sex for me too, you
know? But that's not truly how they feel.
A lot of the time it does mean something
more or they are hoping that it turns
into something more
with that. But I would also say
there's the polyamory community.
There's the swinger community,
there's the kink community,
there's the just sex positive community.
There's people who go to sex parties
every weekend and just have fun with each
other.
I think there are a lot of communities
that you just might not be a part of
where sex just for sacs is actually a
very normal accepted and positive thing,
then that's fine and well.
But I do believe that when two people
are connected in an intimate way,
a soul tie is connected.
And when you are about to enter,
it says another relationship or enter
into something new you're carrying someone
else with. It's like a, it's like a web
that's being weaved into someone else.
It's an emotional attachment.
Um, but to some people,
I do think that they can,
it can just be,
I guess a one and done thank you next,
whatever.
But I do believe that you're carrying
a soul tie when you're physically and
sexually. Um, connect.
I've been shamed for my sexual choices.
Okay.
Yeah, I've been shamed on both sides
cause I grew up in the church too.
And when I was not having sex,
I was shamed by my friends that were,
and then once I started having sex,
I was shamed by people who were in the
church who weren't having sex. Yeah. Yeah.
It's crazy on either side. I think
you're just going to get shamed, uh,
depending on the kind of people and the
communities that are in your life at
that point in time.
There is that aspect of
it, of being shamed for not
doing it right. And you know,
I work at a place where I am one of very
few believers in my company and people
would be like, you don't sleep with
your girl. Come on Bro. You know?
And I've had that in that feeling
of like that pressure of like,
am I supposed to be like,
would that make it easier?
Would my relationship be better?
And like, and you started going to,
is it worth the shame from the church?
Is that worth it? Like, and you know,
and that's,
and that's a constant battle.
I always loved sex and I had a lot of sex
when I was a teenager and I definitely
had comments like, Oh,
Jessica have sex with anyone.
And that wasn't really the case.
Um,
but I definitely got comments like that
and it never really bothered me. I would,
I was always just like, oh, well,
screw you. You know, we're not going,
not going to have sex with you. Now
that you said that. Now in my life,
I get a lot of different attitudes just
based on the way I put myself out there.
But I do treat it as activism because
I think that by speaking out and being
willing to deal with the shame as well
as all the Dick pics and propositions,
I constantly get online. I mean, as part
of the, I think of it as part of the job,
you know,
but it's really important.
And so I'm willing to have
people project their own shame.
Uh,
just real quick,
I want to say a one thing I noticed right
off the bat being the only one on the
outside is that I'm certain
that it ties into my privilege.
I think in my experience,
in terms of my parents and things,
it's been more cautionary
and certainly from a caring,
loving place and I haven't felt any shame.
Yeah.
Sex Ed should encourage safe sex
over abstinence.
I want to run.
Yeah,
yeah.
Over abstinence.
Ah, yeah. I'm just going
to go sit down. Welcome.
The reason why I chose to sit is because
although I'm pro abstinence and I'm
salvage, uh, education is education.
Kids are going to make their own choices.
There's free will. They're going to act
on impulse, they're going to act on love,
they're going to act on
whatever's present to them,
and if you don't educate them on
the safest way to go about that,
how are they going to learn? I don't
believe it should be over apps, Vince,
but I do agree that it's a big
part of education for sure.
Having choice.
I think actually in some ways works for
the abstinence folks because it's like
if you don't, if it's this bad
thing that you shouldn't do,
then of course kids are
going to want to do it.
And so I think like by just giving all
the information and offering choices,
then you know,
people can make a choice.
Yeah.
So I think you guys addressed a lot and
I think when it comes to the education,
because knowledge is power,
we have to teach kids why it is not,
don't do this or God hates you.
It's not that it should be,
we love God.
God sent his son who gave us the ultimate
sacrifice and so we are sacrificing a
physical thing that we
are naturally drawn to.
I disagreed because I think
it your painting just a one
side of something that's
really important, you know, and it's the
safety side, but there should also be,
if you feel like it's meaningful to you,
you should definitely wait until you're
excited about doing this and here's the
safe way to do it.
I still see an imbalance where now it's
becoming taboo to talk about the option
of purity.
My desire is that we don't allow them
the next generation to think that sex is
completely meaningless and
has no emotion or feeling or,
or reason. You know, I think
everyone has their own journey.
Uh, waiting is not mine, but you know,
it could, it's yours and that's awesome.
So, um, yeah, just being
accepting of everyone's sexuality,
whether it be super high
or nonexistent at all. Um,
and just being open to listening to
other people's opinions. All right.
That's a wrap.
Oh
my God.
I'm so glad I pursued in everything here.
Hey guys, this is John. Thank you for
watching this episode of middle ground.
We love the series and we love to hear
what you think about the episodes.
Let us know what you think in the
comments below and let us know what other
topics you would like to see in an
episode of middle ground. And as always,
please be sure to click subscribe
and check out more of our videos.
Yeah.